rapaz o que já é a 50ª vez que temperava
esse vídeo ou áudio está ruim com a luz
ficou ruim o governo arruda tudo muito
você gravada por mais vão gravar
finalmente vamos ter um outro de fãs em
teresina o goianão pelo time vai ser
domingo escutem bem nesse domingo dia 4
de agosto às quatro horas da tarde na
ponte cabana em frente ao palco
principal para ficar abandonada pelo
resgate está lá eu então pra você falar
você estava no shopping eu não vivi
a não ser que eu não vivi até vontade de
conhecer a ter vontade não presente à
vontade isso vontade aqui vai lá no dia
4 de agosto às quatro horas da tarde do
festival principal pode cabando apareceu
lá eu não tive beleza não vamos ouvir
com o outro foi na casa de uma colega
chave é resolver sobre um curta que a
gente está fazendo o que eu escrevi tal
a gente vai produzir aí beleza foi
combate moto foi descer da moto partido
fiel pele esgoto que quase que no odor
do pé
aí o jovem você não sabe o que eu senti
do não com a obra the boys cima da moda
eu fui descer foi bem em cima do buraco
porque não sei o que eu tenho pra que
tanto é que quando eu me machuco quando
ele ralou começa a lembrar das coisas da
minha infância ele toda vez que eu cair
não é pequeno
mãe passado mértola tibete ao lado de ar
dia para cá aí falavam muito é
presidente do metrô lá que alguma
substância que era só pra fazer essa
criança chora e lá pró-vicinais shop.com
se lina chorão ol ela ainda bem
quentinha só em média ruim não que um
remédio que é dos deuses e uma mulher a
escalar era muito gostoso ver um assim
pela pílula azul ou o corte já não tinha
a sensação mais prazerosa que esperar
meus pais sair de casa pra mim não era
bem-vindo remédio pegar quem a efe o meu
deus mas se você é pai de josé mãe você
também assina agora tem que saber o
quanto eu vou encontrar agora um segredo
que vai chocar sobre
pra sempre apronta infelizmente o seu
filho como a essa esconde que você é
dono é duro saber que estou falando de
antigamente é porque e antigamente a
galera conhece hoje a galera já a alambi
camisinha de uva para o melhor remédio
a criança era tracinho não era assunto
de azinho não é de com a fnac não era
catalã não se vê que catar só é docinha
votasse na colher antônio fontoura não
gosto de remédio que me dá até vontade
de pegar o piloto tony curran à afã de
se jogar uma tampa é debater e ficar
dois dias embaixo tava me marcou muito
bom estar na cama da ecobril tarde mas a
qantas catirina antiga de marie o game
roda de boi já confortável quase domingo
com essa borboletinha tá na cozinha a
zema chocolate para marinha pôde puty
ernande epal olho de vidro na hípica
papa
gente alguém pode me dizer que desgraça
de rima é faltar que escreveu essa
música viu que eu tinha direito e que
não tem sentido o conforto não vê que
você chega na casa de um amigo perguntou
se ninguém é cara beleza ou uma beleza é
mais tranquilo a borboletinha porém o
problema do rapaz para da última vez que
eu vi ela tava lá u zinha se não me
engano estava fazendo chocolate para
madrinhas que até aí faz sentido que não
faz um dia depois kaput perna de pau
olho de vidro na picape ao sair só pode
ser a besta fera capiroto satanás que
quando vem à minha cabeça perna de pau
ou de evitarem de [ __ ] pau só pode ser o
saco não foi na metade mas essa eu
aguentava que eu não aguentava essa aqui
atirei o pau no gato tô mais um garoto
tu não morrer ou eu embarco na xícara
catou miro 6 e calmon tube votto beijo
que o gato tem mais bizarro dessa música
não é que que atirou o lugar é reflexão
do caso depois que nativo paulo gato
essa música para superar a força em
porto velho atirei o pau no gato ganso
não morreu eu vou ter que o madrid ou
não até aí eu lamento agora é que
aparece a vilã da história em a vilã da
história em nazaré tedesco da história a
dona chica cada 1.000 cc haverá lá na
porta de casa
meu pai a gente sabe mas tenho a certeza
estão el lugar na cabeça da [ __ ] do
gato ea dona chica o que ela faz
admirou cc do bem ou do gato de antônio
antiga ajuda o gato inverno chiella
ajudar o gato não admirou o terceiro
lugar tem mais que eu falei um pouco a
cabeça no lugar de novo eu vi que o
dinheiro está certo do lanche beliscava
quem trabalha na pipa ajudam os animais
quanto ela cantar tudo bem nem tendo
papel de mãe cantar isso pra gente
possível mas o que me marcou mesmo foi
uma coisa que aconteceu depois que o
funcionário estava lá na porta de casa
etapa que eu gosto de sentar superfã
tina a tirei paulo gato tocando atirou
uma garrafa título é um sonho que eu
acho que a cabeça da gente que faz
refletir volta ao passado mas o gato não
morri kaká virou ser servida de contar
um segredo alguém pode falar no fato do
outro carro já entendo muito bem sobre o
jeito certo não é dona chica cada dormir
ou se é admirou-se sei que é difícil
para você e depois de eu ter escondido
isso tanto tempo de você e você esteve
cantando errado esse tempo todo
quer dizer que esse tempo todo eu tava
tudo errado minha infância inteira forma
faço o meu filho venha cá não não me
toque sem enganar nó esse tempo todo que
eu tenha errado na minha música de
infância de eleição mas eu me recuperei
ficou tudo bem porque eu sou um rapaz
crescido e você entender as coisas já o
adulto que ele pega vocês que eu tenho o
meu teclado canto a iau ela tinha uma
coisa que é o diabo muito pânico e que
era ativo porque queria vol 1 nunca
deixou tomar e tomate com 18 anos eu
acredito não vou dar o máximo pela saída
de grande porte no total button é
fabinho caso não sei não sei há tanto
ruído estado que tudo mais mas ninguém
toque caderno condenados a cabeça de
carga em nota à faculdade e cabo verde
eu tomei também não vivam no comando nem
a vontade de tomar iogurte congelado
vontade que eu contei carioca que tinha
um negócio bizarra 10 mil de fiança em
destino vai funcionar como réu a china
dá medo da noite mais linda dez horas da
noite o pico das vezes eu sou vivo e
fala também de desenhos aqui só que eu
acho que é um cara que é muito melhor
nação do que eu que estou aqui fica
nesse boneco para o canal do carro ele
faz vídeos sobre coisas que vocês não
sabiam sobre os desejos antigamente uma
série de passar antigamente eu gostei
muito do canal e como executar o que é
muito legal e eu queria que você foi
excepcional se inscreve lá assistir um
vídeo dele comenta que foi eu que
indiquei alguns me trouxe aqui alguma
coisa assim era quem falava
o início só tem um mac dada
vamos fazer uma campanha para amanhã com
isso aqui agora eu tenho um boneco e
miley foi a moral tatuí essa página está
na primeira descrição do vídeo que acha
que em teresina que deveria cessar de
volpi e blusa de coisas sentem
é muito acessórios lá acessório para
iscte tem não importe la em nenhum
momento na hora e aí eles resolveram
presentear e simonésia aqui e pra baixo
de muitas coisas novas aqui pra gente eu
queria agradecer a ela na moral a pular
muito obrigado pelos presentes
é isso aí olha é muito importante que
você clique em gostei eu vou explicar
mais porque que divulga o nosso trabalho
você clica em gostei mas a gente vai ver
é muito bom muito bom também se pegasse
o link desse vídeo e montagem é um amigo
que tenho no bate-papo aí pra você viu
aqui eu queria que você curte a minha
página no facebook também minha página
no facebook depois da partida moral
tattoo e machuque e eu também quero que
você comente aqui embaixo que você mais
gostava que você era criança que você
mais gostava quando era criança como é
que embaixo não foi respondida em vídeo
novo isso quando escutamos e aquilo
todos os problemas não se pode resolver
fica nem escrever explicou inscrever
pronto quando tiverem novo você vai
saber sem entrar em efeito no dia 4
agora de agosto às quatro horas da tarde
na potycabana para que você vá lá ea
gente trocava idéia é tirar uma foto
quem tem algum presente alguma coisa que
tenho para me conhecer vai lá e troco
idéias todas minhas redes sociais na
descrição do vídeo também é isso aí
muito obrigado decidir esse vídeo até
aqui e falou